Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de France 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
bajo la ocupación israelí de escena de
miles de familias palestinas se
encuentran fragmentadas y con la
imposibilidad de reunirse a través de
leyes y políticas Israel está separando
cada vez más a los palestinos que viven
entre el estado hebreo y las áreas
ocupadas de gaza si Jordania y Jerusalén
este como consecuencia padres e hijos
pasan años sin verse y hay esposos que
no pueden vivir juntos Más allá de la
habitual argumento de seguridad las
autoridades israelíes han justificado
estas medidas con un fin demográfico y
es privilegiar la mayoría judía en el
territorio nos acompañan hoy Yanira
Gómez y Federico cué les saludo Yanira
comenzamos con usted cómo impacta esta
separaciones en las relaciones
palestinas
las desestabiliza por completo eso sin
duda una frase que nos han repetido
mucho en esta reporteros es que Israel
también está ocupando las relaciones
esas relaciones hay toda una red
burocrática de requisitos y solicitudes
que está diseñada para complicar que
cualquiera pueda obtener su documento
hasta el punto de cortar muchos lazos
familiares hemos sabido de parejas que
incluso con hijos han tenido que
divorciarse tras muchos años de intentar
conseguir o una residencia o un visado o
perderse eventos familiares importantes
que son cruciales para cualquiera y en
cambio hay otros que te admiten que al
empezar una relación con alguien valoran
si hacerlo no tanto por afinidad sino
por el tipo de identificación que tiene
y las dificultades que podrían encontrar
juntos en el futuro Gracias Yanira
veamos la historia
[Música]
70 kilómetros y 20 años se paran a
Mohamed de su madre en gaza entre La Vid
comparte con ella el mismo mar al que
acude para aquietarse y rememorarla
me gusta mucho porque me recuerda mi
infancia en gaza y sobre todo me
recuerda mi madre
fue muy duro para mí porque mientras
crecía y maduraba cuando estudiaba en la
secundaria mi madre no estaba conmigo
hijo de una gazatti y un israelí Mohamed
fue criado por su madre hasta los 11
años y luego por su abuelo paterno en
Israel que luchó porque obtuviera la
ciudadanía israelí el precio de este
derecho ha sido no ver a su madre desde
2002 y convertirse en una de las decenas
de miles de familias divididas entre
Israel y los territorios palestinos en
su caso sólo pueden encontrarse con un
permiso excepcional que Israel rara vez
otorga nunca lo intenté porque creía que
las autoridades israelíes no me
permitirían traerla Pero ahora sí quiero
No tengo nada que perder y debería
haberla de cualquier forma posible
Este cineasta habla con su madre a
diario pero no por videollamada Así que
ninguno sabe cuál es el aspecto actual
del otro aunque se planteó viajar a un
tercer país no ve bien que ella haga esa
travesía
si pienso en la idea de tener que
reunirme con ella fuera de Israel
me enojo
poder verla es un derecho básico Por qué
necesitaría ir fuera porque no aquí y
los procedimientos Están volviendo cada
vez más difíciles
buscan hacer más difícil que personas
como yo vean a sus familiares en casa o
si es Jordania
solo para mantener una mayoría judía en
Israel
desde marzo de 2022 asegurar el carácter
judío de Israel es uno de los objetivos
de la nueva versión de la ley de
ciudadanía conocida como ley de
reunificación familiar que ha sido
impulsada por parlamentarios como sin
harotman Es la primera vez que una razón
demográfica se incluye explícitamente en
esta Norma que desde su aprobación en
2003 ha prohibido a ciudadanos Y
residentes de Israel extender su estatus
legal a sus parejas palestinas
la ley entró en vigor porque vimos un
terrorismo creciente de quienes vienen a
Israel por reunificación familiar desde
la autoridad Palestina
pero esta ley no es solo sobre eso es
sobre cambiar la demografía
por años Israel enfrentó entre comillas
el derecho el retorno de los palestinos
quieren venir y cambiar la sociedad
israelí desde dentro para que no sea un
país judío Ni democrático
esta orden temporal que sin embargo se
renueva daño también frena
reunificaciones con Estados como Líbano
o irán a los que Israel considera
enemigos ante las críticas este
legislador rechaza que la ley sea
discriminatoria
si un árabe de Israel se enamora de un
árabe de otro lado de la frontera el
Líbano o en cisjordania y quiere casarse
puede mudarse y vivir allí nadie le
prohíbe hacer eso
lo que no haremos es darle la ciudadanía
a su pareja
a metros del parlamento familias acuden
hoy a la Corte Suprema israelí que
atiende nueve peticiones de abogados y
organizaciones contra la ley de
reunificación familiar
diversas políticas restringen los
movimientos y fragmentan a las familias
palestinas pero esta afecta a unas
25.000 que se ven privadas de vivir
juntas en Israel o Jerusalén este cuando
las parejas extranjeras de judíos
israelíes se pueden acceder a una
ciudadanía o residencia
estamos aquí en una audiencia sobre
nueve peticiones contra esta ley de
Israel que discrimina a los palestinos
por su raza al no permitirles reunirse O
casarse con sus parejas si son
palestinas
como
abogado
un centro católico de Derechos Humanos
que brinda asistencia legal a palestinos
de Jerusalén este y si Jordania juntos
denuncian que la seguridad es un
pretexto que Israel usa para rechazar la
solicitudes
hay un castigo colectivo que Israel
intenta aplicar al usar acusaciones
contra personas que podrían ser una
amenaza a la seguridad y asociarlas con
aquellos que están aplicando a la
reunificación familiar pero en realidad
no persigue razones de seguridad
el principal objetivo es demográfico de
residencia
un ejemplo Es que la ley dimita por edad
los hombres solo pueden aplicar desde
los 35 años y las mujeres desde los 25 a
sabiendas de que la mayoría de
matrimonios palestinos se concretan
antes de esas edades estas leyes fueron
diseñadas para asegurar que la
reunificación Familiar no ocurra
estas evitan por completo que las
personas de cisjordania y gaza vengan a
vivir a esta tierra
les impiden venir a vivir con sus
familias e imponen requisitos muy duros
para conseguirlo
los palestinos de Jerusalén son los más
afectados por estas condiciones y así lo
enfatiza tarek Pues no son ciudadanos
sino residentes a los que se les exige
estar probando siempre que Jerusalén es
su centro de vida si se mudan así
Jordania se quedan sin documentos y sin
el derecho de entrar a la ciudad
con esta política Israel está separando
a Jerusalén de sus alrededores los jeros
son limitanos tienen a la mayoría de sus
parientes en sus Jordania Así que los
aísla Esto está prohibido bajo la ley
internacional y todas las políticas
sobre separación familiar pero Israel
Sigue aislando a las personas y haciendo
que tengan que mudarse de sus hogares
para no perder la residencia y a la vez
vivir con su pareja con identificación
de sijordania algunos palestinos se
mudan a barriosos como birhona que están
dentro de Jerusalén pero se ubican tras
el muro dirigido por Israel es la
decisión que tomaron los padres de
Jazmín para lograr una vida familiar
salvo que a ella Este lugar la encierra
el doble porque quedó huérfana de
documento
de repente mi nombre fue retirado del
sistema sin que nos informaran o
avisaran
ahora estoy viviendo sin papeles tiene
identificación sin documentos que
prueben quién soy O por qué estoy aquí
siento que estas cosas pasan de manera
aleatoria que retiran las
identificaciones de la gente para
complicarles la vida en Jerusalén
con 15 años es Jazmín que se sabía
anotada en el sistema junto a su padre
descubrió que ya no lo estaba a puertas
de un viaje escolar
las autoridades israelíes solo permiten
que las parejas de Jerusalén y Jordania
inscriban a sus hijos hasta los 14 por
lo que el nuevo registro recayó en ella
con daños personales y gastos en
abogados
tuve dificultades para inscribirme en la
escuela y en la universidad no puedo
tener permiso de conducir visado o
cuenta bancaria tampoco viajar ni
moverme con libertad sus hermanos uno
mayor y otro menor no han visto alterada
su residencia de Jerusalén viajar con
ellos o con sus padres es imposible para
jazmín
Esto me quitó las ganas de hacer
cualquier cosa porque todo lo que deseo
incluye viajar y todos pueden salir y
divertirse y yo no
pero mantengo la ilusión de cumplir con
mis sueños y claro la esperanza siempre
está ahí
la división de palestinos se agrava que
habitan entre sí Jordania y gaza y a
estas familias Se dirige la ong y ya con
asistencia y representación legal
entre estos territorios palestinos
Israel ejerce una política de separación
agudizada por 15 años de bloqueo en la
franja las visitas familiares dependen
de permisos humanitarios que se limitan
a esposos padres hermanos o hijos
se puede aplicar pero solo si ese
familiar de primer grado se está por
casar
falleció o enfrenta una enfermedad con
riesgo para la vida e incluso en esos
casos está lejos de ser automático que
las personas reciban permisos
existe esta violencia burocrática de las
autoridades israelíes que dificulta que
en la práctica pueden reunirse
peticiones sin respuesta supuestos
papeles falsos o faltantes y bloqueos de
seguridad son prácticas israelíes
habituales para Miriam y cuando el
proceso es exitoso los permisos no duran
más de dos o tres días hasta una semana
la política de separación destruye y
aparte a las familias significa que
Israel está dictando a los palestinos
donde pueden vivir donde pueden trabajar
donde pueden residir después de casarse
con otro palestino
impactando en todos los aspectos de la
vida diaria de los palestinos bajo la
ocupación
Hazlo sala total Jalil de gaza cumple
uno de los requisitos su madre está
enferma de cáncer en 2022 sin embargo
las autoridades israelíes le denegaron
hasta cuatro pedidos a veces dicen que
los papeles son falsos otras que faltan
documentos Pero no se trata de eso ellos
salen con excusas para no darte el
permiso lo siguen posponiendo quieren
que me rinda para que no vaya a gasa
si recibiera el permiso israelí haril
podría entrar en casa a través del cruce
de erez El viaje de dos horas le
costaría 20 dólares Pero ha premiado
valora una opción más cara y peligrosa y
es entrar por el cruce de Rafa esto
supone ir a Jordania luego a Egipto y
desde el Cairo tomaron autobús gastando
con todo 72 horas y 700 dólares cada vez
que hablo con mi madre llora y en
ocasiones me confiesa que teme morirse
sin verme eso me frustra porque Qué tipo
de vida es esa
además de su madre Jalil tiene en casa a
su prometida quieren casarse y espera
traerla así Jordania aunque aún no sabe
cómo él llegó en 2016 y encontró trabajo
en ramala pero también se topó con otra
política y es que Israel que controla el
registro de la población Palestina
también frena los cambios de residencia
de gasa así Jordania mientras Jalil
logró de forma atípica la modificación
sus compañeros de apartamento así como
la mayoría de gazatías Jordania son
considerados ilegales en su tierra soy
empleado de las fuerzas de seguridad
palestinas por eso pude obtener mi
cambio de dirección mis compañeros aún
están esperando todos trabajan mucho
para enviar dinero a sus padres y vivir
una vida digna
de todas estas restricciones israelíes
no está exenta Morgan Nacional de
Estados Unidos
enraizada ramala Aquí conoció a su
esposo sale con el que se casó en 2012
para no ser deportada juntos se tienen
dos hijos Pero ella sigue en un limbo
legal
Así que llevo 20 años siendo una turista
en Palestina mi país de elección donde
vive mi familia los niños cambiaron
nuestra experiencia de vivir bajo
ocupación porque tuvimos que explicarles
que mamá tiene un estatus legal
completamente diferente al del resto de
la familia
ese estatus está estampado en su
pasaporte Israel le puso un sello que la
confina a estar en sys Jordania mientras
sus visados son renovados o por cortos
periodos de tiempo
como consecuencia no puede trabajar ni
acudir a su propia embajada que está en
Jerusalén una situación que padece en
25.000 extranjeros con esposos
palestinos que temen que se agudice con
la nueva normativa de la Administración
civil o kogat el órgano militar israelí
que regula la vida en Jordania
las nuevas reglas que promovió el kogat
aún son un poco claras Y ambiguas para
nosotros tenemos que ver pero puedo
prometerte que no será una buena
experiencia no va a hacer la vida aquí
más fácil y no ese es el punto
Qué tipo de rutina puedes crear para tus
niños que raíces puedes echar no solo
para ti sino para tu familia cuando todo
es siempre tan impredecible
en su casa Morgan y sale cultivan
vegetales y crían animales intentan
educar a sus hijos en la sostenibilidad
aparte de ella coordina una red de 30
artesanas palestinas que elaboran piezas
tradicionales con las ganancias se cuida
un parque en El que siembra árboles
nativos y conciencia sobre la herencia
natural Palestina
pese a todos los desafíos y obstáculos
que enfrentamos aquí construí comunidad
de una forma que no experimenté en otros
lugares que viví
y hay tanto de la cultura Palestina que
amo y adopté adopte este lugar y siempre
Supe que era aquí donde quería Construir
mi hogar
como una Palestina más Morgan intenta
construir una vida familiar también
Mohamed Jazmín y Jalil esa vida que hoy
está sujeta a las políticas de
separación de Israel
estamos de vuelta ahora con Federico fue
a quien le pregunto si la situación de
la familia separadas puede empeorar con
el recién asumido gobierno israelí
claramente el futuro para los palestinos
no es alentador el gobierno israelí de
Benjamín de taniaju se basa en el ala de
la extrema derecha más radical que dejó
ver desde el inicio su objetivo de
expandir los asentamientos en los
territorios ocupados y también su
control sobre los palestinos por ejemplo
una de sus propuestas más controvertidas
es una reforma judicial que limitaría el
poder de la Corte Suprema para revertir
las decisiones que toma el parlamento
esto según nos comentaba el
parlamentario al que entrevistamos
abriría la puerta para que esta ley de
reunificación familiar dejara de ser una
orden que se renueva cada año y se
integrara definitivamente en una ley más
amplia de inmigración sin temer que el
poder judicial pudiera modificarla o
refutarla Gracias Federico hasta aquí
reporteros en la semana recuerde que
para sintonizar esta y las emisiones
anteriores puede visitar nuestro sitio
web France 24.com hasta la próxima
[Música]